juan recibe su primer corte de pelo en
muchos meses el tema del aseo y lavarse
es lo que más le cuesta a este joven de
su nueva situación vivir en una carpa en
la calle una experiencia que califica
como denigrante en chile la sucesión del
estallido social de octubre que afectó
duramente a la economía y la pandemia ha
obligado a muchas personas a
alternativas extremas para estadio
social perdí me pega y no puede seguir
pagando más arriendo y después nos
fuimos para santiago y llegando por
suerte llegamos diante de la pandemia y
por situación de trabajo y había puro
despido del día a día entonces estaba
muy difícil las cosas hasta el día de
hoy ocho meses después sigue en la calle
juan y su pareja guillermo eligieron
este lugar de santiago centro porque
había otras carpas cercanas y por las
cámaras pues temen por su seguridad y
han sufrido ataques también de la
municipalidad el día anterior a la
entrevista se llevaron su carpa con sus
documentos personales
la carpa todo lo que tengo todo todo
todo para ellos es basura ante el
aumento de carpas este grupo de amigos
decidió organizarse hacer colectas y
reunirse para preparar paquetes con
comida carpas y útiles de aseo personal
que entregan cada dos semanas surgió
porque un grupo amigos vecinos empezamos
a ir a más gente en situación de calle
más de lo normal uno en general como es
y no teníamos menos claro los sectores
donde había en carpas pero eso se
multiplicó en una calle pasó de haber
una carpa de 4
como que nos sentíamos un poco como de
que ellos estaban muy desvalidos según
estimaciones el número de carpas aumentó
entre 300 y 500 durante la pandemia solo
en santiago bajo techo
en el pacto no más un techo frágil y
nómada para un colectivo amenazado por
la pandemia y por la inseguridad y
olvidado por el estado